welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and morbius the latest sony
anti-hero in the spider-man adjacent
world just released a trailer with many
confusing spider-man references walking
a precarious line between really the two
types of superhero movies the kind where
it's not connected just its own thing
just enjoy the movie nerds or b it's all
connected to one specific cinematic
universe so buckle up for cameos and
crossovers and easter eggs but morbius
seems like he's trying to do both
brooding like a solo story but also with
a ton of details grounding it in at
least four different cinematic universes
this is gonna come right after sony's
gonna bridge together previously
separate franchises in spider-man no way
home so there might actually be some
logic to what's going on in morbius so
let's ask the question where the hell is
morbius on this web of possibilities
let's first lay out all the evidence
that grounds this movie in the universe
of venom which we should be clear is
still a separate universe from the mcu
despite the let there be carnage
post-credit scene because venom left
that universe behind in order to
teleport into the mcu the trailer ends
with morbius name-dropping venom who the
hell are you mad i
am i know
yeah morbius is impersonating the lethal
protector's big move that he used to use
on people like the one who robbed miss
chen what the hell are you
we
are venom so at the very least morbius
must come from some same universe as
venom to be able to know that west coast
lead the protector well enough to name
check him venom was also referenced in
the trailer by fbi agent rodriguez we
haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco now sure
that thing in san francisco could refer
to a lot of things but in this context
it does read like a reference to the
events of the 2018 venom which was kind
of on the level of a crime scene
scenario in which the life foundation
was exposed for human testing using
alien symbiotes or as they said in that
movie symbiotes but then there's this
daily bugle newspaper it has the same
masthead from the sam raimi films and
venom let there be carnage but as i went
into in way too long of a rant in
yesterday's breakdown there is just all
kinds of weird design inconsistencies
with this prop that is just kind of hard
to know how much we can trust it so i
will come back to it but of course there
is an argument to be made that sony is
really just trying to plant morbius in
the main marvel cinematic universe as
much as possible because who wouldn't
want their movie to be in that i mean
how else can we explain the appearance
of michael freaking keaton as adrian
toombs vulture returning from spider-man
homecoming in the mcu wearing even the
same white jumpsuit that he wore in that
movie's post-credits scene kitten even
appeared back in the first trailer in
january 2020. michael morbius
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing huh what's up doc
and now this trailer shows us the end of
that conversation hey uh dr mike you and
i should stay in touch
but one question here when you leave
your home and venture out into the wet
and cold are you wearing some big old
nasty boots that feel and look like
concrete blocks on your feet well you
should be rocking some sleek comfortable
vessy shoes thanks to bessie for
sponsoring this video besties are the
perfect everyday shoe they're
sustainably made knit sneakers that are
100 waterproof they keep your winter
feet dry and warm without any of the
clunkiness of boots they're made with
this diamond text material that's super
easy to clean with just a rinse of water
my shoes got all wet but hey wouldn't
you know it thanks to these messy knit
sneakers my little piggies are boom dry
thanks
whatever the season these are truly an
everyday shoe
which is sealed for besties are your
go-to shoes to keep by your front door
check them out in the link below and get
yourself a pair of vessies then there's
this weird graffiti of spider-man
labeling him as a murderer implying this
spider-man is facing the same scrutiny
over mysterio's death that he is now
facing in no way home but as i pointed
out before this spider-man art is not
the spider-man from the mcu but one from
the sam raimi era yeah this image of
spider-man is actually the raimi-era
suit design from the ps4 game loading
screen we can also come back to that
daily bugle newspaper again the same
masthead from the rainy verse however it
does not have that same new york posty
tabloid front page design used in both
let there be carnage and the rainy films
arguably there's an even bigger clue
pointing to the setting of the mark webb
andrew garfield spider-man films ozcorp
tower appears in trailer footage and
while the building is a different
structure the oscorp logo is exactly the
same with the same unfinished r and the
p also that daily bugle mentions the
existence of spider-man villain black
cat who was being set up in the 2014
mark webb amazing spider-man 2 film with
felicia hardy being played by felicity
jones newspaper also mentions a rhino
incident at the zoo but rather than
referencing the paul giamatti character
from that movie i just think that one
was meant as a little joke reference to
rhinos in general but finally there are
just some marvel easter eggs in this
trailer that suggests morbius is in his
own universe that might be separate from
those other four just because that daily
beagle design is so inconsistent like
it's not the splashy tabloid from the
other universes but a more traditional
six column broad sheet with a poorly
worded headline that j jonah jameson
would never approve also horizon lab
exists that's the tech workshop from the
comics that until now has not shown up
in any live-action movie universe now
the cynical explanation for all this is
that sony probably just wants to get
fans hyped to see morbius with as many
provocative references to alternate
spider-man universes as possible because
morbius himself is a lesser known
character in the comics really best
appreciated for his connections to
spider-man and the blade and behind the
scenes i do think that is what's going
on here but within the world of these
films i still think there could be a
narrative justification here to be
specific i see three possible
explanations for the narrative reasons
as to where morbius is exactly theory
one morbius is in a shared mcu
spider-verse after no way home this is
really the straightforward fan narrative
the one that's gonna be easiest for us
to swallow really suggesting doctor
strange's spell in no way home merged
all of these separate spider-man
universes including that of venom which
morbius may have started in and now
afterwards it's just all one big pot
that is technically labeled the mcu or
maybe the mcm marvel cinematic
multiverse now again morbius was going
to come out a year before spiderman no
way home was going to so maybe sony
originally planned to be a bit vague
about all these crossovers but now that
it is coming out after they're like [ __ ]
let's do it and it went back in in vfx
things like oscorp and horizon maybe did
a bit of reshoots added some new adr
references to the mcu just went crazy
but theory too morbius is actually in
his own pocket reality really the goth
table to the mcu go with me on this
perhaps when that multiversal incursion
occurred finally broken in the events of
no way home maybe some spider-verse
elements were actually sequestered to a
separate side universe left behind in
hell of broken toys including morbius
michael keaton vulture black cat oscorp
from the 2014 film a really weird daily
bugle all while the big boys duke it out
in the main mcu two separate universes
cool kids stable and goth kids table
which is really the even cooler kid's
table the venom shoutouts the rainy
spider-man murderer graffiti those could
be clues for things that actually left
this reality behind and stepping back
behind the scenes since it really just
leaves uh everyone's favorite toys in
the mcu toy box i would consider this
kevin feige's narrative but then there
is three it has always been a
live-action spider-verse and it has
always been connected i mean whatever
you think about this the safest way to
narratively justify all these crossovers
is to just say a prayer of gratitude to
kang who in loki established that the
timeline of the mcu is unfolding all at
once and the rules of cause and effect
don't matter and that the multiverse was
always destined to scramble therefore
the multiverse has theoretically already
been in a state of chaos with various
glitches warping around us under our
noses with no character ever questioning
that reality so there is no clearly
defined mcu or clearly defined sony
verse only the in association with
marvel verse and morbius exists on just
one street corner of this scrambled
multiverse but now able to see it all
and since it's the reality sony is
clearly trying to pull over our eyes we
can call this scrambled mess pascal's
omelette
there's always a chance
ultimately here's where i stand with how
much morbius is in the mcu currently
compared to the other realities coming
back to our pie chart here that michael
keaton vulture cameo carries a lot of
weight we're talking about a major
villain from the mcu showing up in
another franchise i mean you can't get a
bigger thwiff so i'm going to say at
least he's 35 in the mcu but remember in
the mcu the daily bugle is not a print
newspaper so with the venom shout outs
in the trailer i'm going to say 40 in
the venom universe the oz court
buildings pretty big one i'm going to
say the web universe is a solid 10
and then the final 15 left over is
however you interpret that graffiti
could be the rainy verse or it could
just be part of the mcu and whoever drew
that graffiti is just very imaginative
but what explanation do you most prefer
for where morbius is support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at nyrockstarsmirch.com follow
me on instagram twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you